it looks like the end for the  Confederate flag I think that's a good  thing but there's one usage that has  gone unnoticed until now I'm talking  about Six Flags amusement parks the this  is true the original Six Flags was in  Texas it was named for the flags of the  six different nations that have governed  Texas Spain France Mexico the Republic  of Texas the USA and the Confederacy  this is true now obviously this is a  real problem for the company that's why  earlier today Six Flags released this  new ad  [Applause]  five flags hey you probably didn't know  what the six flags stood for in the  first place so our bringing it up was a  huge mistake  [Applause]  wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my  youtube channel for an endless supply of  me  [Laughter]